[Musik]
mit ruby ​​jack of elements gehen
Mitte mit diesem anderen Stürmer aus dem
reds sein profil weiß nicht wo die sind
Tänze in den Stopps Auslaufen von Verletzungen
im jahr 2000 kinn und skifahren ist mario
vargas llosa zur Vergebung ist traurig
der Hinweis, wo schließlich das Land von
wales literatur der zufriedenheit ohne
Variationen auf dem Feld vor dem Festlegen der
indische mahatma behandelt ihr haus heilig gut
nichts erfreut mit Vergnügen
und Vargas die indigenen Taxis von
Cross-Genre-Audio-Gläubige und
Respektieren Sie die politische Formation x5 in Crack
Intellektuell sogar aus Peking Thema dies
sommerliches Getümmel ethischer Hacker und Atsa
Umwelt besteht
Nun, ich habe viele Bedenken, nicht nur eine.
allein politisch
vielleicht
Ich mache mir Sorgen um die Verschlechterung der
Demokratie aus Sicht
Kultur der Verfall der Kultur in
unsere zeit ich denke kultur kommt
für mehr Menschen als in der Vergangenheit, aber was
ankommt, ist eine Kultur, die dadurch sehr verschlechtert wurde
Ich denke, man könnte sagen, der Triumph von
Bilder über Linux-Ideen
Rafael-Phänomen
Nun, schau, ich denke, unsere Zeit ist a
Zeit, wenn Bilder
durch das Kino des Fernsehens
soziale Netzwerke haben eingenommen
Vorrang vor Ideen und dass diese hat
erlaubt Kultur sagen wir ankommen
zu viel mehr leuten als vorher denke ich das
Eliten verschwinden, aber dass die
Kultur, die ankommt, ist ein sehr
verarmt sehr verschlechtert, weil die
Bilder werden nicht durch die angereichert
Gedanken, zu denen sie in gewisser Weise haben
kommen zu ersetzen
segen akten gefängnis wo zur politik
des lateinamerikanischen Skipasses
weicher Ausdruck Politiker auf Abruf
der alten Steaks / Präsident von
Attraktion kommt auf die Schleppe
zeigte den Stil der Neuronen der
Gaddafi, der die Polizeiausstellung überfallen hat
kan Wochentage oder Offenheit der Soldat
Das Vorhergehende lässt Sheffield optimistisch zurück
vor 30 Jahren hatten wir Diktaturen
fast von einem Ende zum anderen
Lateinamerika mit Ausnahme von
costa rica uruguay chile
heute, weil wir Demokratien haben
die meisten Länder
Lateinamerikanisch, aber tief
von der großen Korruption betroffen
Problem unserer Zeit in Amerika
Latina Ich denke, es ist Korruption
diktaturen in lateinamerika gibt es nur wenige
Venezuela
und was wir dann haben, sind Demokratien
unvollkommen, sondern eine Demokratie
unvollkommen ist eins zu eins vorzuziehen
Diktatur das große Problem, das wir haben
Worauf es heute ankommt ist
Korruption Korruption ist sehr
weit verbreitet hat enorm beeinflusst
im fall von peru fünf präsidenten oder in
ins Gefängnis oder von der Macht untersucht
gerichtlich oder geflohen, weil es ein Symbol ist a
wenig von dem, was in vielen passiert
Lateinamerikanische Demokratien mit einigen
Ausnahmen zum Glück
chile-uruguay ende
aber das große problem denke ich in
Lateinamerika ist Korruption
Unterschied zu dem, was in Europa passiert
wo das große Problem der Populismus ist
die wiederauferstandenen Nationalismen und so weiter
sie verarmen nicht verschwinden
aber wenn die stark verarmt
Demokratie haben sie das verkauft
Eigenschaft nicht vorgeben, so zu sein
Funktionaler Index demokratisieren
Democrativo Spirituals in Costa
auch vielleicht vom Knochen rein
Lateinamerika schicken sie mit dem Kopf
demokratisch in tibet
einfach und effektiv zusätzlich zum cfi
Neurotischer Reim in China
in singapur von katrin geschrieben mit der
neuesten Weltabschlüsse
flydubai
Ich glaube, dass demokratische Ideale
gibt es dieses Streben lebendig
Es ist selbstverständlich, dass Menschen in a leben
Rechtsstaatlichkeit, wo die
Menschenrechte, wo es eine Macht gibt
unabhängige Justiz zu sanktionieren
Verbrechen
das sind tiefe Bestrebungen
menschlich und ich denke, sie sind in Reichweite
Menschen sogar aus der Dritten Welt
Menschen aus sehr bescheidenen Ländern mit a
Kultur ein bisschen primitiv, aber großartig
Das Problem ist
Institutionen, wenn sie arbeiten
Sie verschlechtern sich oft
interne Korruption gibt es nicht
eine Verarmung der Institutionen
was sehr ernst ist und unter anderem
liegt daran, dass wir keine Richter haben
unabhängige Richter, die die sanktionieren
Verbrechen und viele Male, dass Menschen
wähle Herrscher, die entweder sind oder sind
Sie werden von der Macht korrumpiert, weil
Dazwischen gibt es keine Sanktion gegen sie
eine Art Philosophie, in der Menschen
davon voraus in der italienischen lang
demokratische Tradition, die ihrer würdig ist
17.16 verlassen Flora Blick auf den Fall von
England ist sehr traurig, weil ich gelebt habe
Viele Jahre in England hatten viel
Bewunderung für Institutionen
Englisch und für die
demokratische Qualität der Bürger und
Beachten Sie jedoch, dass sie in a gefallen sind
absolut primitiver Nationalismus
primär durch Demagogie und so
bedeutet erfolg die bruchstelle ist a
eine Art Rückblick auf das Schlimmste
Dritte-Welt-Idee eines der Länder, die
wir betrachteten ein Beispiel für
der Rest der Welt, was bedeutet das
das bedeutet, dass Demokratie
ist immer bedroht, dass es immer gibt
der Ruf des Stammes, der kann
sogar am meisten verschlechtern
fortgeschritten auf dem Gebiet der
Institutionen demokratischer Qualität
Deshalb finde ich es wichtig
permanente Mobilisierung innerhalb a
Gesellschaft, um eine Abkürzung zu setzen a
Bremse
zu jener Verschlechterung, die zu a
Land zu dem Chaos, das es angerichtet hat
Beispiel in Venezuela in Venezuela gab es
eine venezolanische Demokratie ist eine der
potenziell reichsten Länder der Welt
Welt und sehen, was in den Händen von a ist
Bande von Demagogen
die versuchten, den Sozialismus wiederzubeleben
nach kubanischem Vorbild und dass dies
dass sie es geschafft haben, zu zerstören
praktisch gibt es in diesem Land mehr als 3
Millionen von Menschen, die geflohen sind
Land hungert, es gibt keine Arbeit
es gibt keine Medikamente, es gibt sowieso kein Essen
wird von einer Militärbande unterhalten
es ist nicht wahr, sehr beschädigt und sehr hart
sehr repressiv, weil schau dir das Beispiel an
absolut tragisch finde ich da
Ein Teil ist sehr traurig für die
Venezolaner aber andererseits ist es ein
Beispiel, was man nicht tun sollte
Modell zu folgen, weil
offensichtlich schließt dieses Modell kein Land aus
der armut nimmt ihn nicht aus dem weg
Ungerechtigkeiten glaubt, dass schafft Schlimmeres
Ungerechtigkeiten, die Sie unterdrücken wollen
Leute, wenn Sie vor dem Update sind
beides im Einzelnen
eine Eingabe von einem Tag, an dem Minecraft das
Nachmittage für diese Kunst ist pur
Ablenkung und Sensoren sammeln
Individuen haben künstlerische Gesten
indianista eine Einheit
diese art in zentralen cannes schätzen und
die Hansons und die Existenz dieser Notiz
individuell wie Fleck fragt, glaube ich
dass einer der großen Fortschritte der
Die Menschheit hat das Individuum geschaffen
Das Individuum existierte am Anfang nicht
als es die Stämme gab, die a gaben
Schutz zum individuellen Wohlfühlen
gemeinschaftliches Zusammenleben kann
eine Verteidigung gegen eine Welt sein, die
feindselig gefühlt
dann mit dem Fortschritt mit der
Zivilisation ist das Individuum gegangen
geboren zu werden ist erschienen
und sich von den anderen unterscheiden
anders als die anderen ist einer der
große Errungenschaften der Zivilisation
anders sein, um ihre eigenen wählen zu können
Ideen, auch wenn sie im Widerspruch dazu stehen
die der anderen wählen ihre Sexualität
zum Beispiel
und wählen sogar ihr Geschlecht sind Rechte
die wir dank der erhalten haben
Zivilisation damals
Individualismus aufzugeben ist a
Wahnsinn geht in der Zeit zurück
kehre rechtschaffen zum Stamm zurück und ich glaube
das ist was es bedeutet
Nationalismus das Wiederaufleben
Nationalismen in Europa, das ist
verursacht so viel Schaden an der Konstruktion von
Europa und die Nationalismen, die in der
Dritte Welt hat es schon immer gegeben
wurden immer von aktiviert
Demagogen
ist die Rückkehr des Stammes ist der Ruf
von einem
perfekte Gesellschaft, die es nie gegeben hat
Die Wahrheit hat in dieser Gesellschaft nie existiert
integral homogen wo jeder
sprachen die gleiche Sprache hatten die gleiche
Bräuche verehrten die gleichen Götter in
wahr, das gab es nie
aber das ist eine ideologische Fantasie
zurück in die verlassenen Länder
zu ihr und ich denke, das wird bekämpft
grundsätzlich mit Ideen, aber wie in
unserer Zeit der Verfall der Ideen
seine Ersetzung durch die Bilder, die können
viel grundlegender sein
und sehr fiktiv, sehr künstlich
hat das Nachwachsen gebracht
Nationalismen, von denen ich denke, dass wir sie haben müssen
Kampf
sehr energisch sehr entschlossen
wenn wir Zivilisation wollen
Fortschritt als das, was falsch ist
kann noch gelöst werden und wir wollen nicht
Gehen Sie zurück in die Vergangenheit, sagen wir das Schlimmste
Aspekte der Vergangenheit und das hat Kultur
dann geht literarisch das feuer aus
akte der individualität manufaktur andrás
suche mit al asad, die diese rauchen
Intel stoppt und das Paradies ist gut
es ist ein alter Menschheitstraum
praktisch in allen Ländern
Es gibt immer den Traum von der Gesellschaft
perfekt
dass viele ins Jenseits hinein projizieren
Leben nach dem Tod und einige
naiv glauben, dass man das schaffen kann
Paradies auf dieser Erde ist die Wahrheit nicht
Paradies schaffen kann Paradies ist
Es hat sehr unterschiedliche Formen je nach
Leute, jeder stellt sich das Leben vor
perfekt anders dann
aber was, was erreicht werden kann
Es ist ein besseres Leben als wir haben und
das
ist der
die große Errungenschaft der westlichen Kultur
Die westliche Kultur hat es getan
rollen Sie die Barbarei zurück
primitives Leben Leben zurückdrängen
Tier, das war das Leben von uns
Vorfahren und hat eine Welt geschaffen, die
es ist natürlich nie perfekt
Es wird sein, aber es ist viel besser als die
Welt der Vergangenheit, hörte ich ihn sagen
Popper mich das letzte Mal, als du dabei warst
Spanien wenige Monate vor seinem Tod
und sie sagten ihm, aber die Welt ist sehr schlecht
Herr Popper sagte, wenn die Welt sehr ist
das Böse, es gibt Gewalt, es gibt Krieg, es gibt Armut
es gibt krankheiten aber immer so
glauben, dass sie sie angreifen, damit sie es nicht wissen
demoralisiert denken, dass mit all dem
falsch in unserer Zeit haben wir noch nie
besser gewesen wir waren noch nie besser und
das ist eine große wahrheit sagen wir nie
Die Gesellschaft hat so viele Anstrengungen unternommen
zum Reduzieren der Unterschiede zum Helfen
sagen wir den Schwachen denen, die es nicht tun
Auf eigenen Beinen stehen können wir noch nie
eroberte sowohl die Natur als auch
sagen wir, unsere Zeit hat Fortschritte gemacht
außergewöhnlich viele Dinge gehen
falsch, das kann aber korrigiert werden
Weg, sie zu korrigieren, ist nicht auf der Suche nach der
Paradies, aber mit Intelligenz handeln
auf praktische Weise und darin
Freiheit in der Vielfalt, die es zulässt
Demokratie
Demokratie ist die große Errungenschaft
der große Beitrag der westlichen Kultur
für die ganze Menschheit ist es nicht
genau dann ist das der richtige Weg
folgen sehr deutlich aber
Es ist sehr wichtig zu wissen, dass man nie weiß
Perfektion zu erreichen ist ein Streben
ständige Verfügbarkeit von Mitteln
Sofia Alcantara 277 eines Imams, der
nach kant von einer autorin weiches dänisch
des Generals seinen Besuch in den Steinbruchstunden
Zurück Javascript wurde von verstanden
die feindlichen juwelen gegen taifun von weniger
kostenloser Eintrag
Nun, schau, ich denke, dass der große Beitrag von
der Nobel im Besonderen und der
Literatur allgemein
ist es, den kritischen Geist zu bewahren
eine rebellische Haltung gegenüber
begründete die Idee, dass es nicht genug ist
was wir haben, kann angestrebt werden
zu etwas Besserem und dass es möglich ist
es bekommen
Ich denke, das ist die großartige Funktion des
Literatur Literatur macht die
Leser sind unzufrieden mit a
kritischer Geist gegenüber der Gegenwart
Großes literarisches Werk zeigt Armut
vom wirklichen Leben zum Leben
die wir uns vorstellen können
mit dem Stift fantasievoll zu gestalten
Das würde ich abschließend sagen
Aufgabe der Kultur ist es, dies aufrechtzuerhalten
Art von Angst
Appetit auf ein besseres Leben, das ist
in der Essenz dessen, wer wir sind
Menschen Ich glaube nicht, dass das etwas ist
grundlegend und dafür brauchen wir die
Freiheitsliteratur ohne Freiheit
kann praktisch nicht existieren
wird Propaganda wird
eine von der Macht kontrollierte Literatur
von den Kräften, die dann sein, denke ich
Literatur und Freiheit
unzertrennlich und dass Literatur a ist
Grundbestandteil des Bürgers
kritisch finde ich es das
Ideal einer Demokratie mit Bürgern
dass sie nicht manipulierbar sind, dass sie nicht verlassen werden
cajole täuschen durch die Mächte von
diese Welt, die in gewisser Weise reagieren
Realitätskritik u
alles
gib die ideen nicht auf
Emotionen für die Leidenschaften die Emotionen
und Leidenschaften sind sehr gefährlich aus
aus politischer sicht nicht aus
individuelle Sicht ist wunderbar
Nationen haben, aber von dem Punkt an
Aus politischer Sicht ist das Wichtigste
versuche vernünftig zu sein
und Umwelt dieses Land Art Intelelec
Autobiografie-Trailer des Ex des Gesetzes
das set wird ausgegeben die eliten gibt es keine
ein Cyber-Netzwerk sind Politisierung von
fordert Suchtliberalismen sagt
Tradition die kulturelle Linie die Arbeit
der Generation waren individuell und
Kollektiv wie das Tier mit seinen Shows
bereits Gesetz zur Generation und auch sozial
sie sehen uns als die gleichen engel glimmer monate oder
vielleicht sehe ich dann fragende Listen
Nun, in der Tat, als ich jung war, war ich es
kommunistisch, wie ich sagen würde, die Jungen
Unruhig meiner Generation
Wir glaubten, dass der Sozialismus das war
Lösung für Lateinamerika'
das würde uns von den Diktatoren befreien
jener sehr egoistischen Minderheiten, die es waren
die Eigentümer die Eigentümer praktisch
aller Produktionsmittel
in unseren Gesellschaften
und dann kam die kubanische Revolution
das gab diesen Ideen viel Anstoß
und dann gingen ich und einige andere
zu entdecken, dass es der Sozialismus nicht war
so perfekt, wie wir dachten, es war
das löste einige soziale Probleme
aber es verursachte enorme Probleme der Mangel
der Freiheit
eine Wirtschaftspolitik, die in Nr
Teil war erfolgreich
und dann, dass das so wichtig für die war
Freiheit und nicht unterworfen werden a
allmächtiger Wille einer Macht, die
hatte praktisch keine Art von Bremse
Keine Art
kritische Opposition, die es einschränken wird
nun gut
Für mich war dieser Übergang nicht einfach
Kommunismus zur Demokratie
dapd an scott frank bis dahin die ipn
Es ist in Analyselagern und du singst Ninja und
mit derselben Kennung
Schau mal, in den 60ern war ich fünf
Mitte der Jahre mal nach Kuba
sechzig zum ersten Mal hatte ich einen
Ernüchterung über die kubanische Revolution war
wann wurden die umaps erstellt
Die Umaps waren das Akronym eines Euphemismus
militärische Unterstützungseinheiten
Produktion waren eigentlich Felder von
Konzentration
wo die Revolution verwechselt wurde
Konterrevolutionäre zu Kriminellen
Gemeinsame und Homosexuelle, die ich kannte
viel zu einer Gruppe von Künstlern waren Dichter
Maler Tänzer genannt
Brücke und es waren tatsächlich viele
Homosexuelle darunter alle sehr
mit der Revolution identifiziert
überzeugt, dass die Revolution nicht nur
würde das gesellschaftliche Leben aber verändern
auch die Bräuche die Moral, die ging
Freiheit haben zum Beispiel sexuell
und das erste Trauma ist das erste für mich
die ich hatte, als ich so viele entdeckte
dieser Jugendlichen aus der Gruppe die Brücke
Sie waren in Konzentrationslager gegangen
einige hatten Selbstmord begangen und ich erinnere mich
einen Brief an Fidel Castró geschrieben haben
den ich noch nie gesehen hatte
Sagen Sie ihm meine meine Angst meine
Verwirrung angesichts dieser Maßnahmen und
dann bekam ich eine Einladung dazu
rede mit ihm und wir gingen als gruppe
Schriftsteller, die ich mir vorstelle, hatten auch
protestierte in irgendeiner Weise dagegen
die umaps
und wir verbrachten 12 stunden mit der 8 von
die Nacht bis 8 Uhr morgens
Es war sehr beeindruckend, mit ihm zusammen zu sein
weil er eine Naturgewalt war
aber ich war nicht mit dem überzeugt
Gründe gab er an und seitdem war ich es
Sagen wir
mit einer zunehmend kritischen Haltung gegenüber
die kubanische Revolution im Besonderen und
Sozialismus im Allgemeinen und schließlich gab es
die krise des dichters padilla des dichters
heberto padilla das vielleicht du
werde erinnern
ein Dichter, der sich sehr mit dem identifizierte
Revolution wurde Minister für
Außenhandel zu einer Zeit, die er tat
Einige Kritik an der Kulturpolitik
und dann steckten sie ihn ins Gefängnis
Sie erklärten einen CIA-Agenten zu etwas, das war
absurd undenkbar und dann gut
Viele von uns protestierten und meinen Bruch mit dem
Kubanische Revolution kam
dann viele europäische Intellektuelle
dass sie keine Kommunisten waren, aber dass sie es sehr waren
von links wie sartre wie simone de
Beauboir als Mähren als Enzensberger
in deutschland haben sie diesen protest unterschrieben
und ich denke, viele von ihnen haben sich getrennt
die kubanische revolution wie ich
und das war der ausgangspunkt für mich
eine Demokratisierung von a
Neubewertung der Demokratie
und schließlich ich, der in paris lebte
Ich habe viele Jahre in England verbracht
und ich lebte alle Jahre der Dame
Thatcher an der Macht, was für mich sehr war
wichtig
wie ich es in diesem Buch erzähle
Die Ansicht hat mich nichts gekostet
Banderas arbeitet an Objekten andrés
hervís ticas Patienten des Reisebooms und
Explosion von Silber in der amerikanischen Nation
neben einer literatur in europa gabriel
Garcia Márquez Carlos Fuentes
Schneiden Sie eine Image-Politik
Deportationen und Mystik, wie sie sagen oder in
Kultur beim Werfen des Index belegt und seine
Anführer Andy Italianos, der im Kontext steht
Zeiten fehlen
Schau, ich denke, es war sehr schön zu leben
die die Entdeckung durch erleben
europa durch den westen vielleicht durch die
Welt, die nicht nur Lateinamerika war
Revolutionen der Diktatoren
aber auch Lateinamerika war
interessante Literatur produzieren
ziemlich originell kreativ
und viele Lateinamerikaner entdeckt
lateinamerika in europa wie war mein
Fall, bis dahin lebte ich in Peru
ohne viel zu wissen, was passierte, gab es a
groß
Mangel an Kommunikation in Amerika
Latein und oft ein Peruaner nicht
Ich wusste, was in der Kultur passierte
Ecuador in Chile in Kolumbien in Brasilien
und viele von uns haben das entdeckt
es gab einen Kontinent mit a
Gemeinschaft mit ihnen geteilt
Probleme mit der gleichen Geschichte mit der
dieselbe Sprache, die a produzierte
interessante Literatur eine Literatur
ziemlich kritisch natürlich und gleichzeitig
ziemlich Freizeit ziemlich kreativ
Erfindungsreichtum
Es war eine sehr anregende Erfahrung
wirklich, weil uns das erlaubte
Viele spucken diesen Fidel natürlich sogar aus
Freundschaft erste Freundschaft war a
Sagen wir, es ist sehr anregend, etwas zu teilen
Diese Anerkennung erlaubte uns
widmen uns der Literatur mit a
viel höhere Lieferung als wir hatten
es dauerte nicht lange, sagen wir mal diese Freundschaft
Brüderlichkeit
Die Politik spaltete uns wie immer
aber es waren sehr anregende Jahre und
Vor allem war es die Entdeckung von
Lateinamerika für seine Schriftsteller, die
Es war auch die Entdeckung durch die
Leser, weil Leser begannen
Lesen Sie lateinamerikanische Schriftsteller und
entstand Ich schaffe viel Einheit
kulturell überlegen
als es in der Vergangenheit gegeben hatte
sagt Marketing 3.0 und verschwenderische Politiker
andres betritt die zentrale islip uns
go Fauna konzentriert das große Kuba 17
in Gericht geschoben dank beim Lesen
Angelclip meines Vaters
die Phasen und die Eingabe in die Zeichnung
Es war ein wesentlicher Blick, den ich begonnen hatte
schon in frankreich das ist wo sage ich
Ich fing an, liberale Denker zu lesen
und vielleicht waren die ersten raymond
Aron und Jean Francois Revel
damit, wenn ich dazu kam
England etwas
Ich hatte liberale Ideen, aber es ging darum
alle die Erfahrung der Regierung der
Frau Thatcher, die eine produzierte
echte Revolution in England
schau mal in england gab es respekt dafür
die Freiheiten, die ihnen heilig waren
Englisch, aber das Land war in Frankreich
Ablehnen
und der Rückgang kam vor allem von der
invasive Präsenz des Staates im Leben
allgemein im Wirtschaftsleben im Leben
Freiheiten wurden respektiert
natürlich sehr streng, aber die
Land verfiel, verarmte
es war wie eine mittelmäßige aktion der
Leben sehr beeindruckend mrs
Thatcher hat all dies revolutioniert
vorerst zur Demokratie zurückgekehrt
eine Vitalität a
Ein wahrer Anführer kam heraus, der nein sagte
wir müssen uns davor schämen
Kommunismus hat da was
Kommunismus für uns zu sitzen
unterlegen zu ihm und sie produzierte a
wahre Revolution, die a gab
außergewöhnlicher sozialökonomischer Aufschwung
und ich denke politisch nach England
Nun, es war in diesem Zusammenhang
Ich fing an zu lernen, um zu lesen
Denker wie Popper waren mein großer
Entdeckung war Pop ist wirklich das
Frau Thatcher sagte, er sei der Große
Freiheitsphilosoph der Zeit und ich
Ich glaube, ich hatte sehr recht
sie sagte, sie habe hayek gut konsultiert
Ich fing an, auf der Straße zu lesen, was ich nicht tat
wusste umsonst
hitler in game thing und die autoren
die Autoren, die in diesem Buch erscheinen
sie sind die Autoren, die ich lese, dass ich
immer tiefer in meine geschoben
bereits demokratische Überzeugungen gegenüber der
Liberalismus zu einem Liberalismus dann
nicht-sektiererischer Pragmatiker, kein Liberalismus
was denkst du
alles wird mit einer Wirtschaftlichkeit gelöst
Markt mit offenen Märkten, die gibt
Bedeutung für die Ideen, die vor allem
es ist flexibel
ist der Ansicht, dass die Reformen angepasst werden sollten
irgendwie zu den Bedingungen der
das eigene Land der Gesellschaft und vor allem
ein Liberalismus mit einer Ladung von
soziale Sensibilität nicht wie Adam Smith
der vater des liberalismus war immer a
Mann sehr empfindlich auf das Thema
Armut zum Beispiel
ganz das Gegenteil von dem, was gesagt wurde
so viel Liberalismus, das ist kalt, dass es ist
unmenschlich, wer nur an denkt
mathematische Begriffe nur dies
Buch versucht zu zeigen, dass es nicht so ist
Es ist wahr, dass dies nicht so ist und dass die
Liberalismus und und Demokratie sind
wirklich unzertrennlich
dass es undenkbar ist, dass Liberalismus
kann Diktaturen Diktaturen zulassen
Militär, weil es viel gesagt wurde, dass in der
Fall von Chile eine so brutale Diktatur
wie die von Pinochet in einer Diktatur von
Bei den Neoliberalen gab es Reformen
billig in Chile, das war gut
orientiert, aber es war ein Regime
absolut despotisch brutal e
intolerant, das hat nichts damit zu tun
Beim Liberalismus gibt es keinen Wein
Fahren ohne Design
andersen hände von mir im allgemeinen ist ab
alte finanzierte Fracht für Semis
hat Sturz
weicher Philosoph
in seiner Entwicklung
Schauen Sie sich Poppers Vision an, es ist eine
Ansicht, die zutiefst kritisch ist
des Kommunismus des radikalen Sozialismus das
versucht, an der Verbindungsstelle zu implantieren
sowjetisch in china beliebt in der
sogenannte Volksdemokratien und die
wahr, dass alles, was Popper prophezeit hat
der Fehler wurde in der Realität erfüllt
Donner des Sozialismus, der nicht konnte
sagen wir nie
große Bedürfnisse lösen
sozial war sein wirtschaftliches Versagen
dramatisch nicht nur in der sowjetunion
in der populären china eigenen
Transformation der Kulturrevolution
der Untergang der Sowjetunion u
die Umwandlung von Volksporzellan in ein
Wirtschaftsdiktatur eine Diktatur aber
sagen wir mit einer kapitalistischen Wirtschaft
Es ist wahr, es ist die beste Demonstration von
dass Sozialismus nicht funktioniert
Der Sozialismus löst die Probleme nicht und
die Demonstration, dass Demokratie
westliche Demokratie das Modell von
Die westliche Demokratie ist diejenige, die hat
schufen die am wenigsten unvollkommenen Gesellschaften
Gesellschaften, wo es immer gibt
Möglichkeiten, Fehler zu korrigieren
Verbessern Sie Ihre Ablenkung für die Beine
härter für Plattentasman-Auffrischungen a
Leutnant leidet Wiegen ist schwierig
Netz verhindern
Poppers
verteidige die Demokratie und verteidige a
offene Demokratie, weil es sie gibt
Populistische Demokratien Es gibt Demokratien
und was fahren sie sagen wir mal
der sogenannte dritte Weg ist zum Beispiel
eine der großen Karikaturen
unsere Zeit
Heute wird nicht viel geredet, aber in einem
Moment war die Rede vom dritten Weg, nicht vom
stimmt, dass es nur einen Weg gibt
es ist eindeutig Demokratie, wo es sie gibt
unabhängige Befugnisse, wo sie respektiert wird
an die Bürger, wo Sie können
Ersetzen Sie die Lineale durch
Wahlen
und
Gesellschaften, die sich auf die ausgedehnt haben
Freiheit nicht nur aus dem politischen Bereich und
sozialen, sondern zum wirtschaftlichen Bereich gehören
die erfolgreich sind, sind diejenigen, die haben
wohlhabend sind die mit den meisten
hohen Lebensstandard dann ist es das
Kapitalismus, das ist der Kapitalismus von
unsere Tage ist kein Kapitalismus, weil
wie es sagt
zum beispiel an jesaja berlin den füller
von Kindern die Minen von England in den
Sagen wir mal, im 19. Jahrhundert war der Kapitalismus
vollständig transformiert genau
für ein soziales Anliegen, das es zulässt
Reformen, die den Zustand verbessern
Menschen ohne Errichtung von Diktaturen ohne
diese geschlossene Regierung aufstellen
monolithisch, das ist derjenige, der zerstört hat
Länder, in denen Sozialismus als
das passiert in venezuela zum beispiel nicht
schickte logie zurück nach hitler zitiert
zuerst in bali bezahlt
Verzögerungen
Sehen Sie sich die Ideen links und rechts an
sind in unserer Zeit unrealistisch
an einer Stelle stellte ein klares dar
ideologische Spaltung, aber heute in
Tag sagen wir
Sehen wir uns den Fall von Spanien an
Die katalanische Unabhängigkeitsbewegung ist links
sie wären aber gerne links
es kann etwas reaktionäreres mehr geben
absolut rassistisch zu glauben
den anderen Spaniern überlegen
weil man nämlich in Katalonien geboren wurde
eine Dummheit, die nicht das Geringste hat
Sagen wir
Kraft und biologisch ist das Gegenteil
ist eine groteske Karikatur dessen, was es ist
er
Demokratie ist nicht wahr, das zu denken
es gibt überlegene Völker und Völker
minderwertig ist, was sie glauben
Nationalisten und daran glauben sie
Katalanische Nationalisten sind, wie Sie können
zu sein, dass der Linke der Linke ist
Ich sollte sehr empfindlich sein
soziale Probleme, da was ist
sensibel für soziale Probleme
die Gesellschaften, die am weitesten fortgeschritten sind
dass Feld die Wahrheit, was die sind
Länder, in denen in Europa sie die haben
bessere Lebensstandards, wo das Leben ist
beste und schweden schweiz
das sind sozialistische Länder, das sind Länder
demokratisch sind Länder, die sich bewerben
grundsätzlich liberale Politik und
das hat es ihnen ermöglicht, Fortschritte zu machen
finanziell aufzuholen
Avantgarde von ganz Europa, weil die
Beispiele sind ziemlich stark, wissen Sie
jetzt ist es wahr, es gibt Verformungen der
Liberalismus gibt es sagen wir Einstellungen, die
sind unvereinbar mit dem, was ist
demokratischer und sozialer Liberalismus und so
dann musst du sie ohne irgendwelche ablehnen
nichts, was Vorurteile ist, nichts, was dazu neigt
Männer zu trennen oder zu unterscheiden
wegen ihres Glaubens oder wegen ihrer Religion oder
wegen ihrer Rasse ist es akzeptabel, es ist nicht
stimmt aber das wird von allen behauptet
große liberale Denker
sie erscheinen einfach in meinem Buch und warum
dass ich versuche, in gewisser Weise ein Liberaler zu sein
sehr schlau, weil 'nicht vom sicab eines
elegante Realität, obwohl so viel
besser so viele Stile für alle
Freundlichkeit Säuglinge jede Dimension
verbreiten feuerwehr frei dienstag
Bezirke der ap ohne Kanten, die
kommen Sie zu unserer würzigen Tradition und
Kammer meiner Dürre
Nun, ich denke, die Erklärung ist sehr
einfach suchen die Autoren nach dem
Paradies-Abonnenten suchen die
Perfektion
das gibt es sozial nicht
Perfektion findet sich in
Kultur in der Malerei in der Poesie in
Musik natürlich nichts vielleicht in der
Denken in der Philosophie, sondern in
menschliche Realität, dass Perfektion nicht existiert
wird es nie geben und die Demokratie ist die
politische Anerkennung dessen
Unvollkommenheit, die das Sein charakterisiert
Mensch, deshalb die Autoren
Sie schauen im Allgemeinen auf
Demokratie und glaube an diese Fantasien
die perfekten Gesellschaften die Gesellschaften
wo es nicht sein wird
die Notwendigkeit wird alle vorbei sein
wir werden es deshalb in unserer Reichweite haben
es existiert nicht, es ist eine Fiktion, eine Realität
und der Beweis ist der Zusammenbruch der
großen sozialistischen Imperien unserer
Zeit gibt es keinen einzigen Fall der Gesellschaft
radikaler Sozialist oder Kommunist, der hat
Erfolgreich waren es nicht alle
auf schlagende Weise gescheitert
und was sie übrig haben, sind Länder als
Angst vor der Idee des Sozialismus
das dreht sich oft
Reaktionäre und sogar Reaktionäre
antidemokratisch ist der fall von ungarn
Ungarn zum Beispiel ist kein Fall
gruselig in europa weil danach
erschienen kommunismus blätter
da und das wird immer mehr
in einem undemokratischeren Land
darauf achten, ihren Blick ohne Wirkung wegzunehmen
Kaste der Vollkommenheit und demokratisieren die
unvollkommen wo ist clints baby
antidemokratische Jugend und Lehrer
genau so hast du es gemacht
sehr gut zusammengefasst
die Suche nach dem Paradies viele Male
führt zur Hölle und das ist was
Es passiert mit vielen Schriftstellern, die haben
geschluckt sagen wir mal alle Phantasien
sozialistische Kommunisten und was sie haben
produziert sind die Hölle wie Venezuela
Venezuela ist heute die Hölle
könnte wirklich das reichste Land in sein
Lateinamerika' mit den besten Niveaus
des Lebens in Lateinamerika' und doch
Es ist eine echte Hölle, in der sie sind
so satt Millionen von Millionen von
Mindestens drei Venezolaner sind geflohen
des Landes nein, wie kann es sein
ein Modell für Paradiessuchende
Auf dieser Erde muss das Paradies sein
Suchen Sie in den Feldern danach, wo Sie können
Kulturparadies erreichen
kann sagen wir mal perfekt
große schriftsteller wie thomas mann mögen
faulkner, weil sie mit ihren erreicht haben
Romane eine Art Paradies, aber in
in Wirklichkeit kann nur erreicht werden
Gesellschaften, die sich ständig verbessern
was erreicht werden kann das ist möglich
siehe die Einsätze des Löschfonds bzw
carmen ausdruck und romantisch durch
das schwieg von den wenigen Händen
Menschen behandeln, bis sie verworfen werden
eine andere Liga sieben Minuten mit
fliesen aus dem pellet und elcosa punkt aus dem
leben für garcía márquez in malaga sohn
wirklich viele fantastische Elemente sind
einige Momente, um Distanzen zu verlieren
Das ist die behandelte Karte
Anuies Institution von Cam ein Visum
Klicken Sie auf Persönliche Aktionen
Schauen Sie sich die Realität unserer Zeit an
Ja, ich denke, es hat sich viel entwickelt.
viel verändert und ich glaube nicht, dass es so ist
sagen wir zum Beispiel in Lateinamerika
Romane
die diese Realität vielleicht ausdrücken
weil es getan wird, ist es noch nicht
Es gibt wirklich einen Übergang in Amerika
Latein'
die alten Militärdiktaturen haben
verschwunden wir haben Regierungen
sehr unvollkommen demokratisch sehr
korrupt aber das hat heute geschaffen
eine ganze Gesellschaft im Wandel
das noch nicht seinen Ausdruck findet
literarisch
aber nehmen wir an, es wird kommen, weil es sehr ist
interessant was heute passiert ist
Tag gibt es viele Schriftsteller in Amerika
latina' Frauen Männer Dichter
Romanautoren Essayisten dann ist es ein
große Veränderung mit der Vergangenheit, obwohl die
literarische Welt war sehr klein, weil
auch die Leser sind stark gewachsen
in Lateinamerika'
Also bin ich optimistisch und ich denke das
eine sehr reiche Literatur wird herauskommen
kreativ von denen dieser neuen
Generationen
kommen in Orientierungslosigkeit zum Ausdruck
sicán Politisierung des Karnevals durch
Der Reiz ist nicht medial, sondern ein Effekt
sichtbar mit zig Umdrehungen Leben
Nun, du kannst sie töten
Medienrevolution kann die beenden
Literatur, weil sagen wir mal jedes Mal
erlegt eher eine leichte Literatur auf a
Literatur zum sofortigen Verzehr
Spuren hinterlassen, das ist unterhaltsam
und gleichzeitig
Obwohl mehr Bücher veröffentlicht werden als in der
vorbei die Bücher repräsentieren viel
weniger als früher heute
Konkurrenz ist sehr groß und klein
Bildschirm Ich denke, es ersetzt
nach und nach in das, was die große Kultur ist
Massen zum Buch nicht, dass ich es bereue
weil ich denke, dass, wenn die Bildschirme
Trumpf die Bücher
diejenigen, die für die Bildschirme schreiben
sie werden viel mehr Literatur machen
oberflächlich viel banaler mehr
künstlich als die, die geschrieben wurde
für die großen bücher wird es keinen mehr geben
Dostojewski oder a
Thomas Mann
Tolstoi
Ich denke nicht einmal
Die Autoren werden immer mehr verlangen
größere Präsenz
Ich bin froh, dass ich nicht hier bin, wenn das so ist
passiert und im Durchschnitt hat die Revolution
aufgezeichnete globale Software und sagen, Satz
der Band, die eine Dominante gechartert hat
die starke Dominante im Rücken
kein zweifel von englisch jon science in
herausragende Skulptur und Industrie und nicht
Kommune interkulturelle Weltöffentlichkeit
Erscheinen des Planeten des Willensbüros
schnell 1 Jahr niedrig
das wird nicht passieren das wird nicht passieren
dass es sehr naiv wäre, das zu glauben
Schauen Sie sich zum Beispiel den Fall von Spanisch an
Spanisch ist eine sehr lebendige Sprache
konkurriert in vielerlei Hinsicht mit Englisch
Wir haben ungefähr 50 Millionen
Spanischsprachige nur in den USA und so
Nun, es ist außergewöhnlich und ich glaube nicht.
Sagen wir, gehen Sie alles zurück
Im Gegenteil, mein Eindruck ist, dass wir sagen
Es gibt Sprachen, die koexistieren werden
Es gibt Sprachen, deren Kultur gehen wird
immer mehr imposant
und am Ende dann
bleibt in diesem kostenlosen Spiel von
Kulturmarkt stimmt nicht
Sprachen als sehr universelle Sprachen und
dann Sprachen, die viel mehr sein werden
klein, die eine Gültigkeit haben wird
alle regional national
aber unterm Strich bin ich es eher
optimistisch denke ich, dass wir sagen, wenn die
demokratische Kultur herrscht und jedes Mal
mehr wird am Ende auferlegt, es wird Frieden geben
vor allem, dass es etwas sehr sehr sein wird
wichtig und ich denke, wir sagen es la la
Vorhandensein von Englisch in irgendeiner Weise
ist schädlich für die Menschheit
gut, dass es zwischen den verschiedenen gibt
Sprachen alle, die wirklich sind
universal, in dem wir uns verstehen können
alles das ist nicht schlecht das ist gut das ist
Stimmt, die Handelsknochen 'la flaca'
und Beziehungen des Nationalismus zum Volk
vermittelt angst und klar mit ihr
Wende
zum Sprint, wenn er seinem Festmahl lauscht
gut in einigen Fällen vielleicht aber
ist das nationalistische Kriterium, das wir hätten
es nach und nach auszurotten, weil es a ist
Kriterium, das der Zivilisation widerspricht
Fortschritte und Fortschritte in was
besteht aus diesem Feld glaube ich, dass die
Kongressfortschritt besteht aus Gehen
Grenzen verschwinden jedes Mal
die grenzen verschwinden immer mehr
mehr und das ist gut, nicht wahr
das ist sehr beängstigend für Nationalismen
und sie stützen sich sehr auf diese Art von
Zum Beispiel die Europäische Gemeinschaft
die gründung europas macht vielen menschen angst
sie haben Angst zu verlieren, sagen wir mal
seine kleine seine kleine heimat nr
Sie glauben, dass diese kleinen Heimatländer existieren
Das gibt es nicht mehr und die große Revolution
Technik unserer Zeit
Kommunikation ist im Guten verschwunden
Teil aus wirtschaftlicher Sicht
Ganz zu schweigen davon, dass jedes Mal die Wirtschaft mehr ist
es ist stärker globalisiert, was sehr gut ist
ist eine Sache, die Ländern erlaubt
Arm, hör auf, arm zu sein, zu einem Großen
Geschwindigkeit im Vergleich zu früher
aber
was sie nicht sagen sollten Angst
ist, dass kleine Kulturen werden
verschwinden, dafür gibt es keinen Grund
dass sie im Gegenteil verschwinden, weiß ich nicht
Erwarten Sie so unterschiedliche Wege in beiden
die zuccotti kultur franz peter mit a
McCarthy
es ist meine kultur in velay schätzung in cannes
und es ist die Stadt
sagen wir nicht, in der Kultur sollte nicht sein
in den Händen von Kaufleuten natürlich nicht
aber nehmen wir an, es gibt einen Markt, der existiert
im kulturellen Bereich ist es nicht wahr
bestimmte Länder, in denen aufgrund ihrer großen
literarisch-musikalische Kulturentwicklung
philosophisch bildlich, wie sie die fluten
Welt rechtzeitig, die wir nicht sollten
Sagen wir, wir lehnen es ab, weil wir nein sagen
Land hat die Pflicht, hervorzuheben
zu viel in einem kulturellen Bereich einige
haben sich abgehoben und rechtzeitig für die
Menschheit Kultur profitiert die
Die Menschheit kommt dem Land selbst nicht zugute
das produziert es dann ist alles so so
relativ zu dieser Zeit, gerade weil
die außergewöhnliche soziale Mobilität
Intellektueller, der existiert, der nicht sein kann
sagen, dass heute die Revolution
Amerikanische oder englische Belletristik
oder Französisch nein, das macht nicht viel Sinn
die Wahrheit
was passiert, kommt uns allen zugute und
was passiert, tut uns allen auch weh
Gleichzeitig denke ich, das ist einer von
Die guten Seiten der Globalisierung
erlaubt im Panorama der Welt zu agieren
und das in der kultur war schon immer toll
Präzedenzfall war die Kernkultur nicht
nie lokal war die wahre Kultur
immer international profitiert
alle gleichermaßen und ich glaube daran
Bereich werden wir immer weiter vordringen
bis ich glaube ich das große problem habe
Was wir haben, ist die Präsenz
manchmal sehr hinderlich für die Kultur
der großen Medien
Die Kultur, die sie verbreiten, ist a
sehr schlechte Kultur ist eine Kultur gemacht
von Wiederholungen
von Cartoons die Hälfte von Dosen
sofortiger Verbrauch so viele Rechnungen
Banking meiner Elitezeit
du verstehst so viel kultur in sprint la
Aktion der Situation ist weniger kulturell
und es ist unser Standard Ich ging in die Bar
Nun, sagen wir ja, ja, ich denke, es ist
Wahrheit die Eliten unserer Zeit
tendenziell verschwinden
Ich denke, es ist ein Fehler, das zu denken
die Eliten müssen verschwinden
gibt es unbedingt, sagen wir mal in der
Kultur im Allgemeinen gibt es eine
Spezialisierung eine Verfeinerung in
bestimmte Aspekte in bestimmten Bereichen, die
nur eins erreichen das ipd nur eins erreichen
-Kleiner Sektor sehr Minderheit niemand
kann, sagen wir, die breite Öffentlichkeit verlangen
Informieren Sie sich über die neuesten
Entwicklungen in der Linguistik
und Sprachkenntnisse erwerben
absolut außergewöhnliches Vielfaches
das ermöglicht Ihnen den Zugriff auf verschiedene
Kulturen ist das dann unmöglich la la
Existenz von Eliten notwendig ist
nützlich ist wertvoll
und gleichzeitig
Es ist sehr wichtig, zwischen zu unterscheiden
was wichtig ist und was nicht
wichtig
heute gibt es einige Philosophen darüber
alles in frankreich sagen sie das schließlich
Wir haben eine demokratische Kultur, die
erreicht alle, aber was erreicht
für alle sind die romane von
Fernsehen die Serie, die nur sehr wenige
die haben echt qualität
kreatives Original, das aufgerufen werden kann
sagen wir ein großer Beitrag zur Kultur sind
Unterhaltung ist dort sehr gut
Unterhaltung habe ich keine
Einwand im Gegenteil, ich habe Spaß, ich sehe
TV-Serien auch, aber
Sagen wir, ich vergleiche das nicht mit den Großen
Literatur zu großer Musik zu großer
Poesie Ich denke, es ist sehr wichtig, dass
Stellen Sie diese diese Unterschiede und jene fest
Aufträge
und nur so können wir
Holen Sie es sich durch die Eliten
Große Kritik kommt zum Beispiel von der
die Eliten lehnen dann das cbi ab
Aus demokratischer Sicht denke ich
dass es ein großer Einfallsreichtum ist und dass es aufmerksam ist
gegen die Kultur selbst nicht gewählt
endlich von sich
und fehlende Richtlinien in Venedig
die Gegenwart, dass sie dir folgen, ohne zu sein
Markieren Sie vorher auf Ihrer Maus den oberen Druck
Insel und schließlich
ein werk unserer zeit ein klassiker
Wenn ich einen Klassiker zitieren kann, würde ich zitieren
die große Arbeit der spanischen Sprache, die
es ist don quijote, don quijote ist ein lied an
Freiheit don quijote de la Mancha
Don Quixote de la Mancha' ist ein Mann
frei ist ein Mann, der sich von unterscheidet
die anderen Männer, weil er mehr an die glaubt
Bücher, die im Leben und dann
verwandelt sich in einen fahrenden Ritter und so weiter
Wahnsinn, dieser Unsinn, der uns ausmacht
macht uns zu einer Art Helden
maximal gut, wenn er ein maximaler Held I ist
Ich glaube dem, der es wagt zu sein
anders ist derjenige, der es wagt, seine zu verteidigen
Individualität über allem
Er ist ein Mann, der auch daran glaubt
Freiheit demonstriert es mit der Art von
Leben, das macht ich denke, es ist ein Buch, das
ist auf der ganzen Welt so erfolgreich
vor allem, weil es das darstellt
Ideal von Individualismus und Freiheit in
was wir Liberalen glauben, don quijote
der Fleck
gehen Sie Aktivität dank
entscheiden freut sich über die Verlängerung der
Fürstentum
Spaniens Briefmarken ist, dass es sich kaum summiert
Stufe
von lynn diverser bandvereisung auf
das Projekt einen Moment im Hintergrund
fühle sie gegen die Freiheit
[Musik]